Hi folks, this is Jeff Posnick
from the YouTube developer
relations team.
And I'm coming at you
with another episode
of YouTube Developers Live.
We're going to continue our
series of shows focusing
on the ways developers can move
from version 2 of our data API,
to the newer version 3.
And today's topic
covers something
that's a little less
technical, but certainly
important for developers
to understand.
And that's how quota works
in version 3 of the data API.
So anybody who's had a
history using YouTube APIs
knows that understanding how
quota works is quite important.
It is possible to run
into quota issues.
If you're too aggressive
with the types of API
calls that you're making.
And there are some
changes in how
quotas are handled in
version 3 that we're
going to cover shortly.
So the best overview of what's
new with quota in version 3,
is that there's a
lot more visibility
as to what's actually going on.
The quota in
version 2 of the API
was a little bit more opaque.
We didn't have any exact
numbers attached to operations.
We didn't tell you-- you've
reached 50% of your quota usage
on this given day.
You just kept making calls
until they stopped working.
And you got a quota error.
And best practice,
at that point,
was to pause a little bit and
then try to make calls again.
But in version 3, we have
a lot more information
that we're sharing
with developers.
And hopefully that can
help you plan ahead.
And make sure that you're making
intelligent choices about how
you're using the quota
that you do have.
So, the first thing
to keep in mind,
is that there is a global
bucket of quota that
gets assigned to each developer
registration in the API
console.
Everybody needs to
register before they
can use version 3 of the API.
And everybody gets 50
million quota units.
If you played around
with the data API
back when it first
launched, you might
have seen a lower limit
of 5 million quota units.
We bumped that up to 50 million
quota units a little while ago.
And that is something
we definitely
anticipate should be enough
quota for the vast majority
of uses out there.
So the way those
quota units work,
is that there's
really a global pool.
And every time your
application makes an API call,
some quota gets
deducted from that pool.
If you get down
to zero, then you
run out of quota for the day.
There is also some
shorter term quota limits
that are in place to
protect a rogue instance
of your application from going
completely out of control
and draining all your quota.
And that's actually
something that you
have a little more control of.
Setting what you want
those per-IP or per user
limits to be.
So, let's take a deep
dive into the tools
we have for understanding
the quota usage.
And managing those
quotas and per-IP limits.
And I'm gonna pull up a
screen share right now.
And you can see
what I have opened
here is this page,
that we have a link
to from our documentation.
From
developers.google.com/YouTube.
You'll find it in the
left hand nav over here,
under data API version 3
tools and quota explorer.
And this gives you
insight as to how many
quota units each of the
different version 3 operations
consume.
And just a basic rule
of thumb, operations
that are read only time
especially searches
tend to take very
few quota units.
And operations that involve some
sort of writing, or uploading,
or deleting things tend
to take more quota units.
So if I go over here.
And say, I'd like
to do a search.
And the only thing that you
can do with a search is a list.
And you're saying you want
to get this snippet back.
That's going to end up
costing you two quota units.
So you can do 25 million
of those a day basically.
The reason that there is this
column over here for parts,
is that we do charge a little
bit more for additional parts
that you request.
This comes, not so
much for searches,
but if you're doing a
videos list, for instance.
And you say that
you want to get back
both the snippet and
the content details.
That bumps it up from
three quota units
to five quota units.
And the idea being, we have
to retrieve a little bit
more information
on the back end.
So it's going to cost
a little bit more
for you to make that call.
Still though, that
particular operation
cost five quota units.
You can make 10 million of those
per day from your application,
basically.
Let's try a couple of other
things, like write operations.
If we're going to go
over here and say,
we don't want to do a playlists,
insert, and specify this.
You'll see that this
is 53 quota units
for doing a playlist insert.
So a little bit
of a higher cost.
Because this is a write
operation application,
it can't do quite
as many of them.
And again, still,
we think the quota
that we give people by
default is quite generous.
And, finally, the
operation that ends up
taking the most quota currently
in the API is a video upload.
And again, to specify
this part over
here-- maybe we'll put
in status or something
too-- that bumps it up to
1600-a-quota that that takes.
So that still lets you
do quite a few uploads
from your application per day.
I think something around 30,000.
So that's not a small
amount, by any means.
Even though this
operation does cost more
from a raw quota
cost perspective.
We still think it
should be enough to get
you going for most of your uses.
And I wanted to jump,
now, to some tools
that you could use
to actually see
how much quota your
application that is already
live out there is consuming.
And help you intelligently
plan for what's going on.
And this is done via the
Google Developers console.
So I'm over here.
And it's a sample
application that I have--
accessviacloud.google.com/console.
And I've gone over here
to the APIs section,
under APIs and auth.
And I've chosen the Data API v3.
And you'll see here,
this actually gives you
quick access to
the API Explorer,
that we've talked about before.
But, what I wanted
to do from over here,
is click on the Reports button.
And this is going to take me,
actually, to a different page.
Which is a little bit more
of our older interface
for interacting with
the API's console.
But this is the
interface that shows you
how much quota your
application's actually
consumed on a historical basis.
Actually, let me rephrase
that-- it shows you
how many operations
your application made.
So this is a raw
number of API calls.
And, probably, it is a little
small on the screen right here.
But you can see it's a nice
little chart for data API
v3 usage.
So this doesn't directly
map, in this chart,
to the actual quota consumed.
In order to do that, you kind of
have to dig down a little bit.
And take a look at the
methods that your application
has been calling.
And you see over
here that there's
been 2.3 million
search list operations.
Some playlist items
list operations.
And so on and so forth.
And it gives you a good idea
as to what you're actually
doing from your application.
If you have just written
some simple script
and you've deployed
it to your server,
and you're the only
one running it,
this probably isn't
as interesting
as if you've written
an application
you've released
on some app store.
And you really are interested
in seeing how much usage it's
getting for all the different
API methods from all the users
out there.
So, hopefully that's useful
information for folks.
There's also just one
extra tool that I'm not
going to go into too
much detail about.
But it could be useful.
This is Quotas, from
that same tab over here.
And if you go to the
Set Per-User Limits,
you will see you'll
have a chance
to change the quota that
each individual user
of your application is granted.
And you'll see over here,
for data API v3 for instance,
the default is two units
per second per user.
So if you do have an application
that's deployed widely,
and you are concerned that
the default limit is not
large enough.
Or you want to tighten
the default limit a bit.
You have the ability
to adjust it over here.
And make sure that no single
user of your application
can really deplete that global
quota pool all the way down
to zero.
So hopefully this information
was useful for folks
out there getting started.
With the v3 API, or whether
you've already been using it
for a while, and
just didn't know
you can check in on the quota.
And stay tuned for
more videos in series.
And we hope it's helping folks
make the move from v2 to v3.
This is Jeff Posnick from
the developer relations team
and have a great everybody.